19 et il a enregistré tout seul son
allocution
monsieur le président excellences
mesdames et messieurs les survivantes et
est d'immuniser les autres morts voilà
une description laconique que d'honnêtes
à la fin de la grippe espagnole
voilà seront temps un historien de la
médecine allemand sauver laconisme 9 et
le froid dans le dos si nous considérons
la pandémie qui avec laquelle le monde
est aujourd'hui aux prises ce sont 30
millions de personnes ont été infectées
par le virus
près d'un million de morts tu n'en
sommes qu'au début des impacts à long
terme la faim la pauvreté les
déplacements les conflits mme may 2020
ce n'est pas de 1920 l'histoire ne se
répète pas en tout cas il ne tient qu'à
nous qu'elle ne le fasse pas nous avons
le choix mesdames et messieurs et on
peut le voir assez clairement si l'on
considère les expériences que nous avons
fait pendant la pandémie
d'un côté on voit que le manque de
transparence associé à la désinformation
et aux théories du complot peuvent être
fiers mais en même temps on voit se
dessiner la voie de sortie de la crise
sept voix c'est celle de la raison
fondée sur l'expérience dix
scientifiques cette voie celle de la
coopération fondée sur des règles
communes
nous sommes tous liés par ces règles
c'est bien pourquoi je parle aujourd'hui
depuis chez moi puisque je suis en
quarantaine après avoir été en contact
il ya quelques jours avec une personne
qui a été testé positif au virus
j'espère que la technologie fonctionnera
et que malgré ces circonstances vous
comprendrez mon propos mesdames et
messieurs tant que le virus
tant que le virus est dans l'air il peut
nous affecter tout c'est tout c'est
pourquoi ce n'est que lorsque la
pandémie sera contrôlé dans le monde
entier que nous pourrons va surmonter à
long terme ceux qui sont infectées
doivent être au coeur de nos efforts la
recherche d'un vaccin et de médicaments
ne doit pas être conçue comme une
compétition où comme un concours de
beauté c'est pourquoi l'allemagne a
réservé près de trop plus de trois
milliards d'euros cette année pour la
gestion de la crise mondiale en mettant
particulièrement l'accent sur l' onu sur
l' oms sur le fmi et sur la banque
mondiale nous sommes le premier
exportateur de produits pharmaceutiques
et nous ne sommes avec l'un monde
engagés à distribuer les vaccins
potentiels et les médicaments contre la
copie de 19 de manière juste en tant que
bien public mondial
mesdames et messieurs la crise nous
montre aussi que la coopération
internationale ne relève pas de
l'idéologie et qu'elle n'est pas une fin
en elle-même
au contraire c'est un moyen pour
produire des résultats des résultats qui
dépassent la pandémie actuelle c'est le
cas par exemple en ukraine de la
négociation entre la russie l'ukraine la
france et l'allemagne ont été à produire
le plus long cessez le feu depuis le
début du conflit et des centaines de
milliers de personnes à l'est du pays ne
doivent plus aujourd'hui vivre sous la
menace permanente de la guerre c'est une
raison d'espérer que le ce conflit
puisse être réglé à long terme nous
espérons que un engagement intensifs un
dialogue intensif qui se produire dans
le format normandie dans les mois à
venir et compris au niveau politique de
haut niveau en libye aussi nous
cherchons à mettre l'accent sur la
coopération avec l'onu pour appliquer
les décisions de la comprise à la
conférence de berlin à la lettre le
rapprochement entre le gouvernement à
tripoli et les forces de l'est du pays
qui a eu lieu dans les dernières
semaines est un grand progrès mais les
forces extérieures au pays doivent
également se conformer pour que
une solution plus se produire elles
doivent cesser de livrer des armes et
des mercenaires qui ce qui ne fait
qu'exacerber le conflit c'est ce que ne
chercherons à accomplir lorsque monsieur
vous terrer chez moi même nous
rencontrerons et rencontreront les
partisans du processus de berlin à
nouveau au début d'octobre pour faire en
sorte que les engagements soient tenus
les derniers événements dans les
rapports entre israël les pays arabes
dans le golfe ne sont également une
raison d'espérer c'est le résultat d'une
coopération courageuse j'ai été un
dialogue étroit avec mais quand même mes
homologues en jordanie en egypte et en
france dans les dernières semaines et
nous nous sommes d'accord pour dire que
ce nouveau dynamisme devaient être
saisies par les parties pour que des
négociations renouveler crédible sur une
solution à deux états puissent
renouveler les perspectives d'une paix
durable il faut pour cela des compromis
des deux côtés et s'abstenir de la
violence mais il faute et s'abstenir
aussi des mesures unilatérales telles
que l'annexion et la construction de
colonies
lorsque nous les européens nous pouvons
appuyer économiquement ou politiquement
ces mesures nous le ferons mesdames et
messieurs malgré tous les progrès donné
à ce même cette nouvelle attitude
mondial peine à naître le secrétaire
général a appelé au cessez-le-feu
mondiale ce qui a été adapté par les
conseils de sécurité sous la présidence
allemande en juillet mais cet appel et
tombent parfois dans l'oreille d'un
sourd
c'est un problème pour la sécurité du
conseil de sécurité
c'est une catastrophe pour des millions
de personnes dans des zones de guerre ou
de crise qui sont sans défense face à la
pandémie il faut renouveler nos efforts
dans la lutte contre la violence et
contre le terrorisme en scène il nous
faut aussi un dialogue plus étroits
entre les pays de la région les
organisations régionales la communauté
internationale voilà le but de
l'alliance pour le sel du partenariat de
sécurité de stabilité au sahel de la
collation internationale pour le sahel
nous appuyons les efforts de la
communauté économique d'afrique qui vise
à aider le malien à revenir à l'ordre
constitutionnel aussi vite que possible
ce que le peuple du mali de monde c'est
la paix la stabilité et le développement
il faut un nouvel effort international
mesdames et messieurs pour amener la
paix durable en syrie cessez-le-feu
nationale et le processus
constitutionnel globale et véritable tel
que prévu dans la résolution 22 54
telles sont les conditions de la
reconstruction du pays jusqu'à ce que
nous puisions s'envisager cette
reconstruction nous restons fermement
aux côtés du peuple syrien et que nous
étions par une assistance humanitaire
qui doit pouvoir être fournie à travers
les frontières mais la paix est encore
une condition à savoir la justice c'est
pourquoi nous continuerons de garantir
que les responsables des pires crimes
contre l'humanité de meurtres de
tortures de viols rendent compte de
leurs actes devant les juridictions
allemandes et c'est pourquoi nous
appuyons les mécanismes de l'onu visant
à faire longue enquête sur ces crimes
par tous les moyens à notre disposition
ce ne s'agit pas simplement de la série
et ceux qui ne distingue pas les auteurs
et les victimes des crimes ceux qui
foutent la frontière entre le juste et
l'injuste ceux là font trembler les
fondements mêmes de notre ordre fondé
sur des règles ce sont des personnes qui
mettent en danger la coexistence
pacifique elle même et cela vaut pour
ceux qui bloquent les institutions
telles que la cpi ça s'applique à ceux
qui bloquent le sécurité internationales
veto sur veto et qui évite d qui
empêchent des réformes urgemment
nécessaire par des techniques visant à
l'été leye cela vaut en particulier pour
ceux qui contreviennent au droit
international et alors que en tant que
membre permanent du conseil de sécurité
il aurait une responsabilité toute
particulière pour le faire respecter ce
n'est pas la première fois que nous
avons dû voire une violation du principe
existentielle de coopération
internationale en particulier
la lutte ou l'interdiction des armes
chimiques une violation de cette
interdiction comme nous avons pu prouver
que ça avait été le cas avec nos
partenaires
s'agissant de l'empoisonnement d'alex à
une avanie voilà un problème qui touche
la communauté internationale entière
j'appelle la russie à en faire plus pour
faire enquête sur la faire une enquête
qui doit avoir des conséquences lieu se
réserve le droit d'imposer des sanctions
nous remercions nos partenaires du monde
entier de leur appui infléchissable nous
avons besoin de la même détermination
même coopération pour faire respecter
d'autres questions existentielles pour
l'humanité ici encore nous avons le
choix ne pouvons continuer de voir
relier nos forêts où nous pouvons
continuer de nier l'existence d'un
changement climatique produit par
l'homme ou bien nous pouvons écouter la
voix des scientifiques qui ne disent
qu'il faut traiter le changement
climatique pour ce qu'il est à savoir
pour la plus grande menace contre la
sécurité la prospérité le développement
de notre planète c'est pourquoi nous
avons inscrit fermement la question du
climat de la sécurité au programme du
conseil du sécurité dans les mois
dernier nous sommes ravis que la norvège
d'irlande le kenya le mexique et
d'autres travaillent à cela lorsque ils
siègeront au conseil de sécurité l'année
prochaine mesdames et messieurs nous
pouvons continuer de violer les traités
de contrôle des hommes et des trucs de
détruire la confiance qui nous avons
construite pendant des années ou bien
nous pouvons remettre le désarmement et
la non prolifération nucléaire au coeur
du programme nucléaire du problème
intervenant comme nous l'avons fait dans
les dernières années en particulier
s'agissant de la conférence d'examen du
traité de non prolifération les efforts
européens pour promouvoir un accord
nucléaire avec l iran doivent être
également vu sous cet angle il est vrai
que nous partageons les préoccupations
concernant la fin de l'embargo sur les
armes tant que l'iran l'iran menace
israël et déstabiliser l'ensemble de la
région du liban en syrie en passant par
le yémen
cela dit la destruction du jessy pi way
ne nous rapproche pas d'une fin nous ne
rapproche pas d'un embargo sur les armes
au contraire
la fin de ce plan global rapproche
l'iran de la bombe atomique et c'est
pourquoi en tant que signataire du gc
pieux et nous continuons de défendre sa
pleine application et demandant à l'iran
de respecter pleinement l'accord
mesdames et messieurs nous pouvons nous
aussi
regardez comment les les droits de
l'homme sont vidés de leur contenu
alors que nous nous sommes tous engagés
à les défendre
ou bien nous pouvons défendre ceux qui
sont persécutés ceux qui subissent des
abus par exemple les manifestants
pacifiques du bélarus nous avons demandé
à monsieur loukachenko à de nombreuses
reprises d'entamer un dialogue national
avec la médiation de l'eau essais mais
il a rejeté toutes les offres et il
continue continue de faire oeuvre de
violence et d'oppression et ça doit
avoir des conséquences si en tout cas
nous croyons véritablement nos valeurs
et en os accords nationaux
il en est question dans l'union
européenne mesdames et messieurs des
décisions courageuses doivent être
prises en temps de crise 75 ans voilà
soixante quinze ans après la destruction
causée par la seconde guerre mondiale
annoncée par l'allemagne
la communauté internationale a décidé de
s'opposer à la guerre est de promouvoir
la coopération internationale a décidé
d'opposer de s'opposer au droit du plus
fort est de promouvoir la force du droit
et c'est ainsi que le lieu est né trente
ans après après la chute du mur de
berlin et du rideau de fer cette
décision a été soutenue par la charte de
paris la charte proclamer la fin d'une
ère de confrontation des divisions en
europe et l'avènement d'une nouvelle ère
de démocratie de paix et d'unité
aujourd'hui au milieu de la pandémie
c'est à notre génération de choisir soit
nous faisons cavalier seul sans prendre
les autres rencontres et
nous gâchons tout l'héritage de
multilatéralisme
ou bien nous renouvelons cet héritage et
nous montrons que la bonne réponse à la
crise c'est davantage de solidarité
davantage de coopération davantage de
justice
l'allemagne est prête à suivre ce chemin
avec vous en tant que nation
véritablement unis je vous remercie de
bonne santé à tous au nom de l'assemblée
générale je tiens à remercier le
ministre fédéral des affaires étrangères
de l'allemagne de la déclaration qui
viennent prononcer je donne maintenant
la parole à la représentant du belize
pour qu'elles introduisent l'allocution
du ministre
adam farris sprock madame la vice
présidente
j'ai l'honneur de présenter la vidéo
préenregistrée du ministre des affaires
étrangères de bellis monsieur wilfred pl
ringtone lors de cette 75e